[Music]
everyone be quiet
everyone be quiet this is the moment we
all waited for it
let's do this i can't mess this up oh
hell yeah
i can't mess this up oh let's go stop
touching me get the
brick away from me everyone stop i
almost accidentally killed someone there
all right oh
no tasks there okay guys look we gotta
be more aggressive
next time we see something we're calling
them out and to make sure i'm muted i
don't want him to think we're at double
killing
i can't yeah all right stop being so
suspicious
oh oh shoot lights are on i'm too far
from
electrical to fix why is the light still
down all right let's go hop on a vent
here just wiggle up and down
i don't feel safe anywhere where do i go
uh oh wait no okay good good good good
crowd go to the crowd go with the cup
going with the cup toast folky beast
felix and who fixed lights
corpse
okay
oh no ray it was right
do we have actual evidence dead it's 100
ray
i did leaves all right and cycuno did
leaves too
and then lights went out and went to uh
reactor which is far right and i saw
saikuno's body on the bottom
all i know is you just said you were
with him and now he's dead
dude bobby's amazing at this game it
wasn't me i'm not saying much
just trying to not you know mess this up
he's on the vet he was trying to do the
thing with someone and someone betrayed
him if he was on the vent who would he
be doing it with
other than you listen i would not have
reported his rotting body like that well
i have an important question did you did
you break his neck or did you shoot him
i have no idea but i'll vote if everyone
else is that sounds fun
let's do this we got this got her out
done
he's done though feud's managed to get
away with murder
will he again i actually don't know
who's right but i think we're a little
quick to vote there
wait what i can't believe it all right
there's corpse
he's a nice voice that is all can't
remember if pokey
followed up into electrical with the
rest of us
definitely is on toast and beast so that
leaves
pokey felix
oh pokey would have saw that i can't
mess this up
you can't be doing that toast it looked
like he popped out of a vent but there
isn't even a vent there you know what
i'm saying if i die i'm letting
pewdiepie down
i can't do that we have to impress him
this is my one chance to show him like
hey
i'm smart you know what i mean where the
hell did felix just go i mean he could
have gone up
but oh i wanted to catch him on their
way up
felix is just taking care of business
you can't keep
killing pokey over and over again for
real it's me pokey
rhyme style and pewds on oxygen where
was the body
on the oxygen on the right side they
were three stacked
and one of them killed pokey who were
the three stack i don't remember
it's between pewds and rhymes yeah but i
also wouldn't kill in front of three
people did anyone see anything on this
thing it's rhyme
just trust me and vote him my gut is
saying it's wrong yeah i bet it is
it's you
just do rhymes because there's already
some votes bob but if you're wrong you
got to send me that charizard i don't
feel like toa
stands on stacks though it was so bad
my logic was if we get a double kill
here till here we went
they're not sussing jimmy at all we're
trying to get a double here
is he going for that kill toast is using
his liar voice a little bit
yeah yeah
all right get away get away get away get
away sucker
ah so it's pewds right i didn't even end
the reactor you were with me this could
be a vent
voted felix already did it you're gonna
lose if we would have the wrong one here
i'm serious it has to be toast then
jimmy who are you voting uh you want to
vote toast
let's do toe stuff it's not him we do
poods oh no
flawless victory felix
[Music]
imposter again just kidding ah there
it's being corpse this time being
corpses
last time he yelled out imposter he was
innocent right god i lost everyone
ah of course you wouldn't kill me oh
dude i should kill pewdiepie because no
one would believe it oh god the lights
oh god i'm gonna die oh felix looking
hella sauce right now
double kill double kill double kill
actually i got it i got it i got the
classic play watch this the play to end
all place
i called the muting honestly i was just
curious if someone was dead you can skip
no reason for calling it pokey why did
you turn and chase me immediately that
was the other way around you were kind
of scaring me
no no no no no no i'm in front i'm not
away from you oh she's not in front of
me guys
anyone seen cycuno no i've been with mr
beast a lot he was around me
get him out of here wait what right
that's kind of sus
i'm gonna hard clear rey she's 100
innocent yeah toast is clear too unless
i'm being marinated
i think toast just did that so he could
make her a target all right so mr b
seems like he doesn't do his tasks all
the time which is why when i first
played with him i thought he was the
impostor all the time
i'm scared to feel like some pokey
honestly is jimmy clear or is he about
to murder me
no
all right get out of here get away get
away you know going dogs
[Music]
a toast did you report that buddy i did
you're way quicker than me i was about
to press it should we all skip because
we
got a lot of tasks done yeah speed run
past everybody everyone
work hard what do you mean that's a
little weird
yeah that's really weird to say what are
you trying to
if you vote the wrong person out and
then you're gonna get two more kills
right after that we're on eight so we
can vote someone off right
yeah let's go rhyme i say we throw a
hail mary no no no no no
no no no what i'm scared okay
wait before we leave uh how many tasks
do we have left it was like 75 percent
done all right then yeah let's just
let's test thank you
everyone work hard click fast all right
if you're not doing tasks you're sucks
i only have one set of wires left all
right for the memes i want to kill felix
so bad bobby kinda says
no cam's wrong but they didn't see
because it didn't say you had one set of
tasks less which were wires all right
watch this
biggest brain play biggest brain play
ever
as mr beast he kills no exact don't you
do that why would i kill
pewdiepie i don't know trying to blame
it on me
me and felix are following each other
the entire last round exactly which is
why it's a convenient story why you just
killed him and self-reported
you can follow me if you want vote me
off you want to lose bye
jack just killed pewdiepie and then like
i reported it right away he was trying
to self-report
sure he did mr i fumble on the report
button twice in a row
you think jack would kill felix after he
vouched for jack yeah that's the thing
it doesn't make sense which is exactly
why he would do it
i'll take some balls i'll give you that
if you know me you know i wouldn't kill
felix
that sounds a hell of such to me i
literally just watched him kill him
did the person on camera see anything it
was us three in the room
jack killed him and i reported it right
away what do you think corpse
i don't know i hope i'm right here i'm
waiting mr beast what what did i do
you killed felix in front of me either
jack has a really good innocent voice or
it was you i helped
pewdiepie win the subway why would i
kill him that would go against
everything i believe in
shameless he's going all out you know
one of us is it whoever you vote vote
the other one out next round
we won't have the next round if we're
wrong no because like we were the only
ones in the room so just vote jack out
next round because he's imposter
not me felix vouch for me oh well he's
dead convenient
bruh that didn't work i tried to be a
big brain i
i thought i was big brained mr b seems
so innocent though
up until right now everyone just forgot
logic
stick with me please they're grouped
together and electrical what if jackie
was the imposter
pewdiepie just called me shane watch his
stream does he hate me
wow that was quick and easy i'm gonna
try and outplay the clock
find my body find it i just want to
check the cameras
but it's taking a minute
oh there's a body right on top of the
camera room well it can't be all four of
us because we all came in together right
what do you think it is cycle i can say
it's most definitely not jack that dude
that bad of a job that no one thinks is
jack
i fix lights but this is event kill
right how do we know that
definitely between corpse and toast i
think well
we're very close on tasks here's what
we'll do me saikuna and carbs we're
going to go into a little corner you're
not going to put me
in a 50 50 toast you know i hate them
and you know i'm bad at them and i'll
throw and then everyone will get mad at
me
i'm not doing that toast let's have a
chat oh it's gonna happen anyway
yeah the secret spot corpse and toast no
no no no no
no no no i'm not letting this happen
jack jack just go do your test jeff
i'm not letting you do it there's
nothing i could do kill me let it be
me let me die i want
death don't run away from me like this
he hates me
don't turn your back cubby after all
we've been through if toast doesn't die
i'm voting him
just for making me make that decision
you're gonna have to go fix it please
i am not [ __ ] doing it bruh bruh
i hate you all yeah go do it i'll go to
the top one
wow i can't believe this hey
i want some out jack
why didn't you go along with it jack